um I was gonna say uh for you like what
you know we talked about post Malone
earlier these guys like as someone like
poster like Travis or any of these guys
tapped in nope post Malone
Travis said I reached out to Megan
nothing for Megan it's actually going
through a lot you know
so overstood
really the biggest biggest thing I've
ever used that to music Erykah Badu fire
other Dallas Legend
definitely if I always forget she's from
Dallas yeah
[Music]
Erykah Badu
um
and I missed that on it because I was
like see I feel like you got to go to
the restaurant now yeah I'm gonna go to
Houston I got to show in Houston so
we're definitely gonna stop by there
what's your biggest Market outside of
the State of Texas because you're doing
a number so like you gotta have fans
everywhere uh
I can look right now and see you can
look on your back end
on my way your your back here's probably
your Spotify artist right uh I just go
to the United Method there please show
me
ugh
I've been having the worst Cinema lately
but I'm probably gonna say like uh so
outside of Texas
what about on the tour like what's been
the crazy show
we'll sort out the fastest
I mean Texas my out of Texas they've
already sold out but I mean everywhere
every show we done did then
show that yeah like by the time we get
there it's only like 15 tickets left so
that's fire the walk-in is gonna take
that they're gonna take it out yeah
hey Luca or Dirk Dirk oh yeah he got you
the ring yeah come on come on you can't
go can't go against the grain yeah it
can't go against the grain how do you
feel about uh Luca though I mean I feel
like he got dark potential he does you
know like he could be
he seems like not the easiest guy to
play with though I mean it's crazy
because it's somebody that got to be
from overseas to take us there can't be
no hey man that's that but that's Texas
teams in general yeah yeah Ming in
Houston y'all have [__] Tim Duncans
from the Virgin Islands got it Manu
Ginobili
Lucas and Dirk at least you know we love
everybody y'all love everybody I mean
some of y'all love everybody
and then y'all got Kyrie yeah yeah that
was a shot there's not a lot of Defense
getting played
it's like one thing
158 to 152 games all year next year
that's cool we're gonna put something
together man I'm gonna talk to him I got
leverage now I can come up here and talk
to him uh how how much uh are you you
say you got one more album left on the
deal how how close are you to completing
the project
I mean if you asking me I'm done it's
done features and everything
you know I'm not really a big feature
person I've noticed which is great the
with the album obviously rose on the
album I'm sure yeah but that's that's
different that's like
Batman extension of me you know what I'm
saying so like if I I'm I'm the type of
person that would do an album and put
one of his songs on there just just you
know what I'm saying like that so that
don't even become but like with the with
the album I think what I put Eric Banks
on their tape money so I was walking
that was just
Texas you know I was trying to lock in
Texas so like now
you really asking me like my NR is there
asking man come on we got to do some big
features who you think we should do it
took me like a month to finally just be
like
to sit down and actually listen to
certain songs and be like okay who could
fit on this yeah and so
I don't I don't like the
because now that I know the business and
I look at numbers and all of that
some of these artists like there will
reach out and they'll be like oh this
amount of money and I'd be like
bro what you're not streaming right now
what are we doing but I know it's part
of the game so well a lot of these guys
unfortunately they're in positions where
that's part a lot of their income comes
from is features in backhand because
they are not in the most I understand so
you know but you don't get offended when
that happens though because some people
get pissed off and then they figure it
out because I know I know what I would
yeah you know so I understand but
the people that they charge the Army
those people I was just talking about
yeah we're not even gonna do them but
people that I am going to do features
with uh I'm gonna do something with uh
I'm trying to get something with offset
fire I got a song on him
uh who are you saying Fitness finesse
two times I got a song with him
uh like you said bro yeah uh
who else he's running around like
everywhere with that little kid rapper
after the kids he just followed me on
Instagram and I got so excited last
night I sat with him at the BT Awards
and I thought it was his son because
like finesse two times sits with the kid
and I was like hey what's up man I was
like is this your kid you know and he's
like no he's a rapper I was like what I
hate him to Freestyle I asked him to rap
and he said I don't rap for free so I
gave him I had Mexican pesos in my
wallet so I was like here's some pesos
and he wrapped and this little kid was
talking like he was a 39 Year Old
Trapper who just got out of prison
I said what's happening here
it was the craziest [__] ever and I was
like this sounds like the type of kid
that might be raised by a finesse two
times
indeed not his son yeah man that's crazy
I thought that was his kid not his kid
just a kid can you just follow me on uh
King yes he was following me on
Instagram last night and I blurted it
out in the Sprint I see y'all King just
follow me on Instagram so you finesse
anybody else uh right now at the moment
too I just came to hey you're on uh that
Mexican OTS album you gotta get down on
your [__] you know we made that song
two years ago really
was right when we both
started bubbling he reached out to me
and we just at first we was just kind of
vibing and then he sent me something we
did it he came we shot a video for it
like this one he was on his first tour
oh wow yeah so